nous sommes aussi interpellé par nos
concitoyens sur la question des
pastilles diodes
il ya une sorte de fantasme là qui
entend se développer dans notre pays
chacun sait que on ne peut pas utiliser
ces pastilles n'importe comment et en
tout cas aucunement en matière de
prévention je parle sous contrôle de
médecins la matière néanmoins ici d'une
préoccupation et des pressions qui sont
faites sur les pharmacies pour être très
clair bien sûr en espérant que cela
n'arrivait jamais s'il devait y avoir un
incident nucléaire comment on a pu
connaître avec les vents de tchernobyl a
il ya quelques dizaines d'années
est ce que nous sommes en capacité si
les choses devaient s'aggraver y compris
par des mesures
terroristes à l'égard de centrale
nucléaire ukrainienne est ce qu'une
sommes en capacité d'avoir un stock
suffisant pour répondre aux
préoccupations des français sans vouloir
faire de parallèle bien évidemment je
n'oublie pas la question du stock des
masques que nous n'avions pas à une
autre époque problème différent mais
néanmoins préoccupations qui peut
aboutir à la même conclusion serons-nous
prêt au cas où il y aurait un drame à
caractère nucléaire dans cette partie du
monde
sur la question
compliquée de vous répondre publiquement
monsieur le ministre le canard mais mais
c'est une question tout à fait légitime
je n'ai d'ailleurs évoqué moi même ce
matin avec eux avec le comité direction
du ministère de l'intérieur directement
que ce préfet de police et puis je fais
chaque semaine désormais une vision que
les préfets parce qu'il n'appartient
mise l'intérieur d'organiser des crises
de sécurité civile et donc de prévoir
donc j'ai demandé d'abord au préfet un
petit état des lieux notamment de l'état
d'opinion de la population parce que
comme vous sans doute rencontre en plein
de gens dans mon territoire
voilà je pense que l' angoisse autour
des propos du nucléaire est forte
d'abord parce qu'il perd un conflit
potentiel mais aussi parce que nous
avons nos centrales nucléaires et je
crois savoir que dans votre dans notre
département à gravelines d'ailleurs plus
que c'est à 20 km ont distribué des
pastilles jusqu'à 20 qui arrêtait pastis
iode les choses avaient été bien fait je
m'en suis d'ailleurs assuré auprès du
préfet nord zone de défense mais qu'il
convenait de le regarder alors non pas
pour annoncer un éventuel problème mais
pour cent préparer voilà donc à la fois
pour l'état de l'opinion puisque j'étais
surpris par cela notamment par les plus
jeunes de nos compatriotes je sais pas
si vous l'avez constaté vous aussi mais
aussi parce qu'il faut il faut savoir
prévoir des choses au score on est en
responsabilité de la sécurité des
français j'ai demandé un petit état des
lieux mais elle pour l'instant ce qui
m'a été remonté monsieur le ministre ne
démontrait pas de difficultés
particulières mais c'est encore un peu
trop tôt pour que je ne puisse vous
l'affirmez absolue complètement en tout
cas on s'en occupe
[Musique]